y
resultados alentadores una investigación
francesa demuestra que la vacunación
previene casos severos y muertes por
kobe 19 personas mayores de 50 años
participaron en el estudio que apunta
que quienes recibieron una vacuna tiene
el 90 por ciento menos de probabilidades
de ser hospitalizados o morir los
resultados se confirman observaciones de
otros estudios realizados en eeuu reino
unido e israel pero esta investigación
fue más amplia los investigadores
franceses compararon resultados de 11
millones de personas vacunadas con los
de 11 millones sin vacunar a 14 días
después de la segunda dosis el riesgo de
contraer una forma severa de kobe se
redujo un 90% en las personas vacunadas
la vacunación parece ser casi igual de
efectiva contra la variante delta con 84
por ciento de protección para los
mayores de 75 años vacunados y del 92
por ciento para inmunizados de entre 50
y 75 años el estudio francés abarcó la
vacunación con facer variante moderna y
astrazéneca pero no con janssen que es
mucho menos usada en francia
los resultados también sugieren que
durante el periodo de cinco meses en el
que se realizó la investigación la
protección de la vacuna contra el hobbit
severo no disminuyó